and wouldn't you know a little birdie
told us it's world wildlife day
tomorrow and that little birdie of
course rocky diaz
she joins us from the henderson bird
viewing preserve with how we can take a
walk on the wild side here in vegas hey
rocky
hey kirsten yeah so i'm so glad you guys
told that story because lisa here was
just telling me about
ebird.com right yeah and you guys use
that here at the preserve
we do you can go on ebert and if you put
in henderson bird viewing preserve
you'll see that birders have put what
birds they've seen here today so you
know what to expect when you come out
wow okay so we'll get to the you know
how to properly bird here
at the henderson spot but first i want
to know about this land look at this
vast beautiful land where are we right
now and how did this come about
so the henderson bird viewing preserve
actually sits on the water reclamation
facilities property it's over 100 acres
and there's nine evaporation ponds
that the water reclamation facility uses
and uh it kind of started back in the
70s with the ponds here the birds
naturally came
as a place to live or rest on their
migratory travels
and where there's birds there's going to
be birders right
eventually the audubon society's
christmas bird count
added this spot to their annual bird
count and in 1998 we opened up the
henderson
bird viewing preserve to the public that
is amazing and you've told me before too
that nevada is among the most diverse
birds in the world yeah so you can see
over 200
species of birds here at the bird
viewing preserve throughout the year and
nevada in general
sees even more than that different
varieties of birds wow that's so cool
and i i mean honestly i'm a
rookie here this is my first time bird
viewing and it's so much fun it's also a
really peaceful activity safe activity
you can do
during this time and i'm wondering you
know i've heard a lot of different
sounds
walking through here is there a certain
bird call that you would do to
try to attract them over how does that
work so
instead of a bird call you're probably
going to need a lot of patience to sit
down and wait for the birds to come to
you but some
professional birders do use bird calls
to identify the birds instead of through
their physical features
interesting okay well i do i also want
to let you guys know obviously
like we mentioned earlier world wildlife
day is tomorrow
and in vegas you don't think you know
there's a lot of wildlife here but there
is it's the henderson bird viewing
preserve here
and then we have the lions habitat ranch
we have
camel safari there's camels in the
valley did you know that i didn't know
that
see you got to celebrate tomorrow and
beyond so thank you guys i'm ready to go
you know see more about what you have to
offer here but i feel like i'm missing a
few tools
yeah so we're going to want to remember
to bring our binoculars wait don't tell
everybody yet we're going to tell you
what you need
to properly bird watch coming up later
in the show
i'll send it back to you all right rocky
the next step we'll have coming up later